mesdames mademoiselles et messieurs
bonjour laissez-moi vous présenter ce
nouvel aspirateur robot ce n'est pas
juste un aspirateur robot c'est vraiment
un compagnon à la maison qui va vous
solutionner la vie qui va vous aider qui
rendra la vie plus simple et c'est pour
ça que je vous le présente pour ça et
aussi parce que c'est un partenariat un
partenariat avec roborock c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisée
en partenariat avec roborock si vous
connaissez ma chaîne vous savez que je
vous ai présenté un paquet de produits
de roborock d'aspirateur connecté
pourquoi et bien déjà parce que ce sont
des produits extraordinaires qui vous
facilitent le quotidien vous vous
embêtez pas ils vont faire le ménage
pour vous enfin dans 90% il restera 10%
qui seront à votre charge quand même
pour venir à nettoyer le sol mais il va
faire le taf quotidiennement il va
vraiment bien vous simplifier la vie
donc c'est pour ça que j'aime ces
produits et que je tire très heureux de
venir vous les présenter donc ça c'est
le nouvel aspirateur de roborock c'est
le S8 pro
ultra et vous allez voir je vais tout
vous détailler vous allez voir toutes
les spécifications de ce produit tout ce
qui est capable de faire qu'est-ce qu'il
y a apporté par rapport à la génération
précédente et puis bien évidemment six
produits vous intéresse je vous mets un
lien juste en bas dans la description
allez c'est parti on y va
qui est roborock roborock je sais pas si
vous le savez je sais pas si vous
connaissez bien la marque et bien la
marque roborock c'est une entreprise de
technologie qui est là pour vous
faciliter le quotidien en termes d'usage
en termes de nettoyage et d'entretien
chez vous avec des aspirateurs robots
extrêmement compétents et quand je dis
compétences je dis vraiment compétence
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont faire plein de
choses il va venir aspirer nettoyer
automatiquement chez vous sans que vous
preniez la tête il va automatiquement se
remplir en eau propre et vidéo
automatiquement également
il va venir aspirer mais également laver
grâce à sa serpillière toutes les
petites cochonneries qui recueillent il
va les vider directement et
automatiquement dans un sac à poussière
donc en gros vous ce que vous avez à
faire c'est remplir l'eau propre jetez
le sale et changer le sac à poussière au
bout de quelques temps lorsqu'on aura
plus de place à l'intérieur en plus de
ça il est intelligent il va venir
scanner votre appartement en connaître
les moindres recoins les différentes
pièces pour que vous puissiez l'envoyer
alors vous voulez au moment important on
peut même automatiser les tâches le dire
le lundi tu fais ça tu fais ça tu fais
ça le mardi tu fais ça le mercredi tu
fais ça et lui vient bosser lorsque vous
vous n'êtes pas là ou lorsque vous
faites autre chose et en plus déconner
de vos pièces il va connaître vos
meubles il va même venir éviter les
obstacles on peut venir régler pas mal
de choses également le niveau
d'aspiration le niveau des frottements
pour le nettoyage on peut même lui dire
de telle heure à telle heure tu vas pas
nettoyer par exemple la nuit pour pas
être embêté par votre aspirateur qui
reste balader chez vous il évite les
obstacles ils ne tombent pas dans les
escaliers bien évidemment il passe les
barres de seuil très facilement
lorsqu'il arrive sur un tapis bien il
vient remonter sa serpillière bref c'est
l'outil indispensable à avoir chez soi
si on veut pas s'embêter qu'on ait la
technologie donc ça c'est la base des
aspirateurs de roborock et là avec le
roborock S8 pro ultra on a plein de
nouveautés et il fait encore plus de
choses à commencer par son nouveau doc
qui est vraiment extrêmement pratique
donc ça c'est le doc le doc il est
constitué de plusieurs parties vous avez
sur la partie du bas et bien là où va
venir se poser votre robot il va venir
se nettoyer sécher la serpillière tout
va se passer ici et sur l'eau et bien
vous allez avoir la partie plus que vous
vous allez venir manipuler à savoir un
réservoir d'eau propre ici vous avez
trois litres et demi d'eau propre donc
vous voyez il va venir se vider en
fonction de l'utilisation que vous en
ferez et vous avez qu'à venir ouvrir ici
vous retrouvez votre eau vous mettez
votre propre ici c'est pratique ça c'est
très très bien bien évidemment quand
votre aspirateur a fini le boulot il
récupère de l'eau propre et remonte de
l'eau salée elle est juste là ici peut
contenir deux litres 9 Dossal alors là
pour l'instant j'ai un petit fond de
salle votre salle de la même manière que
le prof vous venez vous ouvrez et vous
l'avez ici vous voyez la couleur c'est
pas folichon folichon c'est forcément de
l'eau sale moi ma Rocco c'est de venir
la vider très très régulièrement pour
éviter que ça pue lorsque vous l'ouvrez
que des bactéries prolifèrent et de
temps en temps peut venir nettoyer avec
un petit fond de javel vous voyez moi ce
que fait c'est que je prends un petit
spray javel je viens au fond je le fais
tremper et comme ça au moins bien ça
m'élimine quand même toutes ces
bactéries donc ça c'est le sale et vous
avez juste à côté ici et bien le sac à
poussière votre sac à poussière ça
contenant c'est 2 litres et demi toutes
les poussières qui sont dans votre
aspirateur robot qui sont donc situés
ici vous voyez j'ai aspiré j'ai vraiment
fait le boulot là il est complètement
vide et lui il a commencé à se remplir à
l'intérieur donc lui ce qu'il fait c'est
hop là et bien alors petit aparté votre
filtre que vous avez là vous en avez un
autre qui est tout neuf vous pouvez
venir changer quand celui-là sera
complètement incrusté et complètement
sale donc lui vous le laissez à
l'intérieur il vient tout récupérer il
vient tout monter en fait l'aspirateur
ce qui fait ça c'est vachement
intéressant c'est que lorsque vous
lancez pour la première fois il va venir
il va tourner il va se mettre dans
l'autre sens parce que vous le voyez
vous avez une espèce de petite buse à
l'arrière où il va venir se connecter
cette petite buse elle est située juste
là donc lui qu'est-ce qu'il fait là il
est en train de se charger regardez je
prends mon aspirateur là j'ai des
petites connectiques une connectique là
et une connectique là les deux
collectifs se retrouvent également ici
une là et une là ça ça permet de se
recharger mais vous avez également à
l'arrière tout le système pour venir
envoyer de l'eau à l'intérieur ça se
passe par ici au
que roborock nommé est double brosse
rotative double brosse contre rotatif
parce qu'elles viennent comme ça à
tourner et elles sont en caoutchouc
alors il y a plusieurs intérêts à avoir
ces brosses là la première chose c'est
que votre aspirateur avance il faut
imaginer que là les petites cochonneries
vont rentrer là donc là elles vont être
rapatrier à l'intérieur et si toutefois
elles avaient pas été captée et bien
vous avez la brosse arrière qui va venir
les ramener à l'intérieur et comme vous
êtes sur du caoutchouc ça va vous
ramasser les cheveux les petits poils
avant il y avait des brosses un peu
classique et les cheveux et poils
pouvaient venir s'en mêler dedans ici
c'est pas possible ça ramène tout à
l'intérieur ça c'est vachement bien et
autre nouveauté qui est vraiment bien
ici c'est qu'ils ont augmenté la
puissance de succion au monde jusqu'à
6000 Pascal autant vous dire qu'ici il y
a vraiment de la puissance à des potes
donc pour tous vos besoins d'inspiration
ici vous avez de quoi faire il faut
savoir sur la génération précédente vous
aviez une seule brosse rotative et 2500
Pascal de puissance d'aspiration donc là
franchement ça envoie du bois autre
point qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
le nettoyage des tapis grâce à des
ultrasons il va venir reconnaître la
matière sur laquelle il est donc
lorsqu'il va être sur un carrelage un
parquet et bien vous allez avoir votre
serpillière qui va pouvoir être là et
qui va pouvoir nettoyer sauf si bien
évidemment dans l'application vous lui
dites de ne pas le faire sinon il le
fera et lorsqu'il va vite reconnaître un
tapis et bien qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien votre serpillière va venir remonter
pour qu'elle ne vienne pas frotter votre
tapis pour ne pas venir le mouiller ça
ne servirait à rien et ça permettra de
préserver également votre serpillière
donc vos tapis vont être bien mieux
nettoyer une fois de plus avec les 6000
Pascal avec la double brosse rotative et
bien évidemment la reconnaissance des
tapis il y a une option à venir cocher
dans l'application qui est vachement
bien qui permet de booster l'aspiration
lorsque vous arrivez sur un tapis donc
là vous êtes au max ça dépote et vous
nettoyez votre tapis en profondeur autre
point qui est vachement bien c'est le
vibre à rise 2.0 c'est quoi en fait
c'est votre module vibrant vous allez
venir retrouver ici en fait vous allez
avoir 3000 vibrations par minute ça
permet quoi ça permet de venir nettoyer
plus efficacement toutes les tâches
sèches donc si vous avez une tache de
café une pâte à tartiner cassé au sol là
ça arrive ça vibre ça vous nettoie vous
êtes peinard vous êtes tranquille ça
c'est bien aussi oh autre technologie
qu'on retrouve dans cet aspirateur robot
qui est vachement bien c'est que
lorsqu'il va venir rentrer par exemple
après l'aspiration et bien ça sert à
rien de faire traîner la serpillière au
sol donc il va faire un truc très bien
il va venir remonter sa serpillière
automatiquement mais également remonter
les brosses vous voyez ici ou si vous
voulez passer juste en mode aspiration
et que vous avez pas besoin de venir
faire tourner les brosses hop il remonte
vous êtes peinard je dirais que la
grande force de ce produit là et bien
c'est le fait qu'il est intelligent qui
va venir reconnaître les objets alors il
y a une nouvelle techno qui nous ont mis
ici vous avez le réactive 3D le réactif
3D en fait vous avez un leader à
l'intérieur qui va venir reconnaître les
objets en trois dimensions il va
reconnaître jusqu'à 42 types d'objets
différents et ça même dans le noir donc
si vous avez des câbles qui se baladent
des chaussures lui il les voit il les
reconnaît il les contourne il continue
son boulot le gros point fort roborock
c'est également son application qui est
extrêmement complète regardez ici par
exemple tu vas retrouver mon roborock et
suite pro ultra on voit le nom je vois
qu'il est en charge quoi qu'il 99% de
charge tout va bien et ensuite je peux
venir rentrer dedans directement saisir
alors là je vois alors je vais faire
nettoyage de zone vous le voyez au
milieu je l'ai envoyé ici nettoyer
quelques petites cochonneries j'ai
nettoyé un mètre carré je pourcentage de
batterie et je vois le temps de
nettoyage alors j'ai différentes choses
soit je peux venir lancer j'ai le gros
bouton nettoyant en bas auquel cas je
vais lancer à nettoyage complet de
toutes mes pièces ou alors j'appuie sur
station il va retourner à la station bon
là il est déjà à la station donc ça je
peux venir faire nettoyage global mais
si je veux bien faire un nettoyage par
pièce et bien j'appuie sur pièce et là
je sélectionne une pièce et je fais
nettoyer il partait à nettoyer cette
pièce de fond en comble ou alors
nettoyage par zone comme j'ai fait tout
à l'heure vous voyez j'ai pas un exemple
ça ce que j'ai fait c'est que je suis
venu zoomer sur ma carte là voyez j'ai
mon tapis qui est grisé ici vous voyez
mais le marque tapis donc là je peux
nettoyer soit de nettoyer directement
tout le tapis là ça c'est pratique ou
alors directement juste une partie du
tapis parce que j'aurais fait tomber une
cochonnerie dessus vous voyez par
exemple celle-là si je vais être encore
plus précis je peux me dire zoomer donc
là j'ai cette zone là hop là vraiment
ici là juste devant la table j'ai fait
tomber un truc j'appuie sur Nettoyer il
partait à nettoyer le tapis à cet
endroit là et uniquement à cet endroit
là après je peux venir régler aussi pas
mal de choses j'ai ma petite icône en
bas à droite et là je peux venir régler
ma puissance d'aspiration en mode turbo
sur le tapis je veux que ça envoie
maximum sa tartinamax normal ou alors
carrément extrêmement silencieux bon moi
je fais du turbo ici intensité de
frottement je peux dire carrément faible
moyen intense ça va dépendre bien
évidemment de ce dont vous aurez besoin
puis un parcours alors soit un parcours
standard il va passer un petit peu
partout soit un parcours rapide et le
parcours rapide il est pratique pourquoi
c'est si par exemple pour un petit
nettoyage courant vous avez pas besoin
qu'il aille partout devant ton comble
vous mettez rapide alors ça c'est le
mode aspirer laver vous avez également
le mode lavé vous choisissez le
frottement et le parcours donc ici pas
d'aspiration uniquement de l'aspiration
et même max plus là ça nettoyage en
profondeur et là ça va envoyer un max
bon à vous de voir bien évidemment à ce
moment-là ou alors carrément
personnalisé vous choisissez le parcours
en fonction des pièces vous dites dans
cette pièce là telle puissant dans cette
pièce là telle puissance autre sujet
intéressant pour venir customiser votre
intérieur vous cliquez juste ici en haut
à droite sur cette espèce de petit de
cube vous pouvez choisir le nom des
pièces le type de sol par exemple moi
ici le sol ici vous voyez dans cette
pièce là voyez le type de sol les
meubles les obstacles vous affichez tout
car 2D carte 3D également fort intérieur
ou même carrément la carte matrix si
vous souhaitez le faire bon moi je l'ai
pas fait mais on peut venir le faire
très facilement sans oublier la
modification de votre carte par exemple
je peux venir définir une zone interdite
en lui disant ben tiens par exemple
cette zone là tu n'iras pas vous voyez
soit je mets un mur invisible là par
exemple je dis là c'est la chambre
d'Elliott tu n'iras pas dans la chambre
d'Elliott parce qu'Eliott est grand il
fait son ménage tout seul donc ça peut
être effectivement un mur invisible ou
alors donner une zone interdite en
disant maintient par exemple toute cette
partie là je veux pas que tu ailles donc
tu n'y vas pas et je me débrouillerai
tout seul comme un grand pour venir
faire le nettoyage et si vous voulez
venir le supprimer après vous cliquez
juste là Zone Interdite vous cliquez
dessus la croix hop ça disparaît et
c'est fini bon de la même manière on
peut venir fusionner des pièces ensemble
renommer des pièces bref éditer sa carte
très facilement donc là vous l'avez vu
vous pouvez venir interdire des pièces
interdire des zones l'embry dans un
espace particulier mais on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin regardez on va
cliquer sur les trois petits points en
haut à droite donc là déjà on peut venir
gérer ses cartes vous pouvez donc
définir plusieurs étages si vous avez
une maison ça peut être pratique donc là
j'ai ma carte numéro une mais si j'avais
par exemple deux trois étages et bien je
peux dire les mettre ici ensuite je peux
dire faire les programmes lui dire par
exemple tu vas démarrer par exemple
aller à 14h tu vas répéter ça tous les
jours et tu vas nettoyer en mode turbo
et avec un frottement moyen et ça il le
fera tous les jours de la même manière
je peux dire aspirer la vie juste laver
juste aspiré ou alors venir
personnaliser et je peux lui dire tu vas
partout hein tu vas me faire juste une
pièce comme ça je peux définir une
routine par exemple tous les jours à
telle heure lorsque j'ai fini de manger
il vient il nettoie donc ça c'est adapté
en fonction de votre style de vie les
évitements d'obstacles les gagnants que
je pouvais avoir ici ça je vous en
parler tout à l'heure moins de collision
il vient également repérer les animaux
domestiques moi j'ai un chien c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal les paramètres
des tapis avec l'élévation dynamique ça
c'est plutôt pratique le boost pour le
tapis vous avez finalement le nettoyage
du tapis en profondeur pour venir cocher
ici après nettoyage des pièces votre
robot nettoiera indépendamment les tapis
de chaque pièce cela ne cuit pas bien
évidemment les paillasson puisque un
paillasson c'est pas extérieur c'était
pas dans une maison vous avez également
le paramètre de nettoyage des planchers
nettoyer en suivant le sens du plancher
donc là vous mettez plancher horizontale
plancher vertical par exemple ici c'est
du plancher horizontal c'est la même
chose ici c'est la même chose ici ici
comme ça vous aurez le même sens un peu
partout vous avez également les
paramètres de la station avec
l'intervalle de lavage de la serpillière
et si toutes les 20 minutes donc
lorsqu'il va bien faire du ménage toutes
les 20 minutes il va venir nettoyer la
serpillière je vous ai toujours une
sapillière propre que veut dire modifier
bien évidemment passer 15 10 minutes
jusqu'à 50 minutes bon 20 minutes pour
moi c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
fichu mode de lavage de la serpillière
et si je suis sur un mode équilibré je
peux mettre également en profondeur
vidage automatique bien évidemment mode
de vidage intelligent on le laisse faire
c'est s'ajoute automatique durée 3h la
voie du robot vous la mettez en français
par défaut alors en anglais mais vous
pouvez venir la mettre en français les
paramètres du robot voyons des boutons
une sécurité enfant également mode ne
pas déranger de 22h à 8h du matin ça pas
très bien rechargement en dehors des
heures de pointe à dire que c'est si
vous le souhaitez et puis bien
évidemment la carte en ligne et les
unités qui sont ici en mètre carré
épingler et y aller pour lui dire bah
tiens tu vas à tel endroit claque vous
appuyez dessus et il y va contre la
distance une petite télécommande pour
venir à contrôler votre aspirateur robot
bon pourquoi pas je sais pas convaincu
qui est grande utilité mais si vous
voulez vous amuser avec vous pouvez
l'historique de nettoyages et vous
montez par exemple un grand historique
là il a fait le tour de toutes les
pièces que j'avais laissé ouverte donc
on va exactement où il est passé quel
endroit qu'est-ce qu'il a fait et
éventuellement s'il y a des zones qu'il
a pas fait c'est de comprendre pourquoi
il est pas allé l'entretien aussi donc
là pour l'instant tout est ok je suis à
fond ça c'est quand même très très bien
le manuel d'utilisation et les
informations sur le produit donc vous
voyez c'est très complet on peut venir
ici tout paramétrer tout ce dont vous
avez besoin on est donc sur un produit
intelligent pratique performant qui
fonctionne bien moi personnellement j'en
ai beaucoup d'aspirateurs de roborock je
crois que j'ai commencé avec le S5 donc
j'ai fait S5 S6 S7 la le S8 et du y
avoir un cul quelque chose au milieu et
à chaque fois ça a bien fonctionné j'ai
utilisé sur le long terme donc je les ai
utilisés longtemps et ça a toujours très
bien fonctionné à la maison donc c'est
vrai que c'est un produit malin un
produit intelligent et en plus ce qui
est bien c'est qu'avec cette nouvelle
génération et ce gros dock vous avez
plus trop à dire vous embêter en
fonction de vos usages en fonction de ce
que vous allez programmer vous allez
remplir votre propre vider votre salle
changer votre sac de poussière une fois
de plus ça va dépendre de votre
programmation et de vos usages et de
besoin de nettoyage mais ce qui est cool
avec ces produits c'est que ça permet de
totalement se débarrasser de ces tâches
quotidiennes de venir passer
l'aspirateur régulièrement exemple tout
con vous venez de finir un repas vous
appuyez sur la routine nettoyer après le
repas il peut passer dans la cuisine
dans la salle à manger et c'est propre
vous êtes tranquille donc ça c'est bien
plus besoin de s'embêter ici d'ailleurs
si ce produit vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description vous pouvez y
aller pour l'acheter dans les meilleures
conditions et merci à roborock d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo puis dites-moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des
aspirateur roborock est-ce que
c'est canon c'est
est-ce que vous mettez aujourd'hui avec
les aspirateurs est-ce que celui-ci vous
botte oui non quoi comment marquer moi
ça bien évidemment on va dans les
commentaires et puis moi je donne
rendez-vous très bientôt pour continuer
à parler tech de produits connectés bien
évidemment peut-être d'aspirateur allez
savoir en tout cas ça c'est vachement
cool je vous embrasse à bientôt et
prenez soin de vous Ciao
[Musique]